do you go to every audition um not every
audition like I got I get sense of my
pretty struggle one sometimes what do
you mean I get sent audition sometimes
like it's like hard because I feel like
after I did my first movie I could have
went like two ways I could have been
like a waitress number two and the new
like zoe kravitz movie I could have been
or Ike you know but luckily oceans like
was the next thing so now it's like do I
really want to be on The Good Wife as
like the person that works at the store
to be like a Bravo host like do I look
like a Bravo I don't do I don't do any
of that show yeah I don't mind hosting
but you know not with with like that you
know oh you're on a trajectory is that
the right word specific trajectory
listen to me stricter okay you want to
stay in that [ __ ] trajectory stay in
the pocket yes in the pocket don't do
[ __ ] Wow don't do [ __ ] you know
reality show don't do any of that no I
do if you're on a list [ __ ] and that's
what you're doing stay in the a list
[ __ ] mm-hmm okay what I'll never work
again
that's impossible I'll tell you why
because you have other things that you
do that's the thing you're the maga
you're a MacGyver you know I feel that
you can do all kinds of [ __ ] right like
for me you know one-trick pony
that's nice thank you when when film and
television dried up for me I went you
know what I'm not gonna be on no
Nickelodeon show the [ __ ] they're are
offering me so I'm just gonna do the
road I'll do some videos and I'd rather
do that I could still make money right
and you just hold out and people go how
come you're not in a lot of things
because I say no do a lot of things
right right right I mean I do your time
there's III I think about auditioning
it's like if you meet with the director
and you you you know you might be up for
a role and you don't get it that's okay
because I never went on tape if you go
on tape and then you send in the
director and they still don't hire you
it's kind of like having sex with a dude
and like it's like flirting with the
dude I'm like I'm like text messages
yeah and then having sex with them and
they and then they don't call you back I
don't like with that with that like
pessimistic I don't I can't handle that
yeah I can't handle rejection like it
like in that way especially for the [ __ ]
what some of the [ __ ] I [ __ ] I've
gotten rejected for oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's a terrible feel it's a
horrible feeling but we also don't know
it's another thing of my mind I don't
know what you know we're like when I
just say they say no or they reject me
there's probably like a thousand things
going on that's beyond my control yeah
really
yeah that's how I make myself feel
better with that but it's the truth
yeah yes beyond your control yeah it is
yeah you went Foley high-pitched on that
[Music]